la journée mondiale de l'environnement
c'est toujours quelques jours avant le
grand prix de montréal
alors on se demande à quel point est ce
polluant une course de formule 1 d'abord
ça mange quoi exactement une voiture de
course
la combativité villeneuve reese
accrochage avec la renault même ce
qu'ils n'ont pas vécu se souviennent de
la fin de course entre gilles villeneuve
et rené arnoux à cette époque là les
moteurs sont particulièrement du tout en
fait jusqu'au début des années 2010 ont
parlé de 80 et même 100 litres aux 100
km avec les nouvelles réglementations
on est passé à environ 50 litres aux
cent
par exemple une honda civic ses 6 litres
aux cent
depuis 2014 c'est une volonté de la fia
on a développé une nouvelle génération
de moteurs hybrides
philippe crépeau ça fait 30 ans qu'il
suit de près le championnat de formule 1
donc aujourd'hui les pilotes travaillent
non seulement à l'essence mais également
à l'électricité dans une proportion de
deux tiers un tiers et malgré l'apport
de puissance électrique 20 voitures
alignées au départ vont émettre cette
tonne de co2 pendant la course
c'est l'équivalent de trois aller retour
montréal paris cet automne d'un côté le
secteur des transports au québec c'est
33 millions de tonnes de co2 mais là on
ne parle que des essais et de la course
et c'est la partie émergée de l'iceberg
selon patrick bonin est responsable de
la campagne climat énergie à greenpeace
canada
quand on regarde dans le détail les
émissions sur le circuit représente
moins de 1% de l'ensemble de toutes les
émissions liées aux activités de la f1
et clients évidemment l'utilisation des
ressources naturelles le transport par
avion également transport l'utilisation
des équipements des matériaux la formule
en deviendra-t-elle un jour la formule
eu 100% électrique n'est pas exclu mais
c'est pas pour demain